[Applaudissements]
normalement vous allez bien bon matin je
viens de aussi du québec alors j'ai
pourtant un petit accent comme ça qu'ils
en trouvent ce matin s'est levé on se
disant super j'ai passé une très
mauvaise journée personnes non sans rire
personne
je comprends pas si on prend pas assez
bizarre en même temps mais en fait vous
êtes très très bon groupe et je vais
venir plus tard pour vous expliquer
pourquoi vous êtes très normaux
aujourd'hui même pourquoi on est dans un
contexte dans lequel effectivement il
faut se poser des questions sur les
modes de management
pourquoi aujourd'hui on doit revoir les
choses différemment
et puis quelles sont les conséquences
qu'on a aujourd'hui de son modèle de nos
modes de management et enfin dernier
point que je voudrais vous a mené par ce
que vous dites si ça va pas et si c'est
compliqué et ben il ya peut-être des
solutions mais la bonne nouvelle oui
c'est que je vous apporter quelques
pistes de solution en tout cas quelques
unes dont j'espère que vous allez en
profiter pour les mettre en place pour
vous personnellement
puis peut-être pour vos organisations
pin fine et pour les faits dont on est
parti alors allons-y
on a dans l'introduction
que faisait les manuels il parlait
effectivement que je suis éclaireurs de
transformation managériale éclairé ça
veut dire même deux choses met un coup
de projecteur sur les choses qui sont
importantes
il ya des cas où l'information c'est pas
où sa part de sa part de tous les côtés
on parle de changement sans arrêt il ya
même des personnes qui des consultants
des confrères comme moi qui gère le
changement et le changement est géré pas
il se vit
si je vous regarde non dans cette salle
je suis persuadé les changements vous en
a eu plein c'est dans les deux dernières
années qui d'entre vous a changé de
téléphone portable qui qui d'entre vous
a changé
par exemple de voitures de maisons
deux femmes ou maris ne vous êtes pas
obligé vacances j'ai vraiment donc juste
vous dire une chose
aujourd'hui le changement il fait partie
de notre vie et vous êtes passé par
toutes ces étapes de changement donc
pourquoi on en fait quelque chose
d'aussi compliqué dans nos organisations
aujourd'hui tout à l'heure emmanuel vous
parlez aussi de cette notion de
motivation de travail je vais vous
donner un chiffre
85% 85% ses 85 % des personnes dans les
organisations dans le monde qui centre
des activement des engagés ou d engager
activement des engagés vous imaginez à
peu près ce que ça peut faire vous êtes
dans une boîte puis à quelqu'un qui fait
exactement le contraire de ce qu'ils
devraient faire
la bonne nouvelle pour lui c'est qu'il
est payé quand même pour sa carrière
il ya des gens qui sont juste des
engagés des engagées c'est à dire ils
font ce qu'il faut il pour passer sous
le radar là dessus on est en polynésie
on a une course magnifique qui s'appelle
là où équine wind course de pirogues qui
commence est reconnu internationalement
je vous pose la question est-ce que vous
partiriez aujourd'hui à faire les week
nuit avec un équipage de six personnes
dont il y en a une qui rament dans le
bon sens
3/3 garde cramer
si possible en commentant faisant des
commentaires désagréables et qui est pas
bon ça va pas etc
et puis 2 qui rament dans l'autre sens
vous voyez votre pire hogan ya un type
qui rament la lionne trop mieux qu' 1
et puis 2 kg dans le sens vous avez des
chances des justes nulle part et on à 85
% des collaborateurs dans le monde qui
sont désengagés activement des engagés
donc on a plein de changements partout
dans le monde
on a plein de choses qui évoluent sauf
une chose vous savez quoi il ya une
chose qui n'a pas changé depuis le 19e
siècle ce sont les modes de management
alors tout le monde aime dire ouais mais
le changement et c'est assez compliqué
n'en faut qu'on arrête là parce que
héraclite philosophe au vième siècle
avant jésus-christ disait déjà le
changement est la seule constante
donc nous sommes dans des organisations
aujourd'hui où on à 85 % des
collaborateurs qui sont désengagés ou
activement des engagés et nos modes de
management tu ne changes pas alors que
le changement est la seule constante on
a un vrai problème et ce problème
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils sont un père sauf
sont bien évidemment les collaborateurs
mais aussi les managers d'équipés
certains d'entre vous qui ont peut-être
des équipes qui ont malheureusement avec
ce taux ces faibles de motivation comme
c'est assez faible c'est nul on va dire
a pris un chacha se disent parfois ils
viennent me voir et me disent laurent
las mon équipe c'est pas terrible alors
gratte la tête un peu comme ça je me
gratte pas trop parce que j'ai une île
trop à côté
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour motiver
mes équipes
c'est ce que je leur répond qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour me motiver les
équipes
je leur fais une réponse qui les
anéantit littéralement j'en dis toi ce
que tu peux faire pour motiver des
équipes rien tu peux rien faire harry
viennent pour demander de l'aide et je
leur dis tu peux rien faire je ne peux
rien faire et on ne peut rien faire et
je reviens sur ma première question tout
à l'heure ce matin vous demandant qui
d'entre vous s'est levé on se dise on
chouette je vais passer une super
mauvaise journée
personne personne pourquoi parce que la
science aujourd'hui nous apprend des
choses extraordinaires sur la motivation
que le management tu n'utilises pas du
tout donc je vais commencer à vous
donner des pistes l'aide aujourd'hui de
comment on peut travailler pour avoir
des organisations dans lequel les gens à
la fois prennent du plaisir des
organisations qui soit plus humaines
mais aussi plus durable et plus
profitable qu'est ce que la science nous
apprend on a deux types de motivation au
travail
les motivations qui sont plutôt d'ordre
positif qui sont des motivations qui
viennent de nous mêmes c'est pour ça
qu'en g2 les managers viennent me voir
en disant si tu peux faire pour manger
ton équipe tu peux monter sur une table
et de dire allez les gars soyez motivé
soyez motivé ça avait duré quarante
secondes le temps que tout on le descend
de ta table et que tu tourne le dos la
motivation vient de nous mêmes la
motivation c'est un travail intérieur
personne d'entre vous ici ne s'est levé
le matin en se disant fort que j'aille
au tedx peut-être que certains d'entre
vous sont enlevés ce matin on se dit ah
vous vont se lever lundi matin en disant
on va falloir que j'aille au travail
je vais peut-être vous expliquer
pourquoi aujourd'hui où on n'est pas sur
les bons facteur de motivation
motivation intrinsèque qui re toutes
sortes de nous extraits secs c'est celle
avec lesquels on se compare avec les
autres on va commencer par celles qui
sont positifs premier type de
motivations le plaisir on veut prendre
plaisir à faire ce qu'on fait
cerveau est formaté pour ça depuis l'âge
des cavernes notre format tout notre
cerveau est formaté pour le plaisir
vous allez me dire oui mais dans le
travail parfois compliqué de prendre du
plaisir
on est des métiers où c'est un peu
compliqué et c'est vrai on regarde une
infirmière par exemple qui donne un bain
une personne âgée c'est pas forcément
quelque chose qui donne beaucoup plaisir
mais près le plaisir il ya une deuxième
chose qui est essentielle quelle notion
de sens pourquoi on fait quelque chose
pourquoi on le met en place mais cette
notion de sens elle est fondamentale
dans les organisations
si aujourd'hui vous avez perdu le sens
de ce que vous faites votre organisation
allait commencer un navire sans pilote
sans cape un peu comme mon équipe de
hockey news verra qui va là où elle peut
aller parce que chacun décidé de faire
ce qu'il veut donc première source de
motivation au plaisir si on n'a pas la
notion de sens
cette infirmière qui donne se basent
personnes à 7 personnes âgées sait très
bien quelle est la finalité de ce
qu'elle fait elle avait une personne
qu'elle se sente bien propre qu'on
apporte quelque chose qu'elle soit
reconnue par rapport à ce qu'on fait et
puis on a deux types de motivation sont
des motivations qui vont de plus en plus
dans le négatif la première c'est notre
fameux pitot l'orgueil
dgo
voilà il est beau monde et ça c'est moi
qui les fais c'est faux c'est pas moi
qui les fait l'orgueil légaux qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire le fait
que ben on veut se comparer tu as vu
dans c'est moi le chef
je veux dire ce qu'il faut faire ou
c'est moi le meilleur vendeur ou c'est
moi qui suis meilleur que toi on est sur
ces éléments de comparaison permanente
des organisations auxquelles vous êtes
sûrs d emande comparaison permanente
vous n'utilisez pas les forces des
personnes vous utilisez juste qui ne va
pas bien chez eux
voyons permanence verre à moitié vide
fatigant parce qu'on y est à moitié vide
c'est pas avec ça vous allez réussir
étancher votre soif puis dernière source
de motivation d'après vous qu'est ce que
c'est la pire c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est la science ainsi quarante ans
qu'il ya des travaux qui sont faits
notamment par jacques forest à votre
avis ça peut être quoi salerne argent
ouais
l'argent n'est ne pas le le bon facteur
de motivation mais quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui autour de nous par exemple
sur le fenua je ne vais pas citer les
organisations j'ai pas le droit mais
quand on voit des boîtes dans lesquelles
les gens sont payés 16 mois par an et
puis qui réclament des augmentations de
salaires bas et réclament des
augmentations de salaires vous savez pas
pourquoi parce qu'on ya plus de plaisir
et on a perdu de vue le sens de ce qu'on
fait si vous pensez aux organisations
aussi penser aux tedx le tedx ici il ya
plus d'une vingtaine de bénévoles une
trentaine de bénévoles qui travaillent
sont des bénévoles c'est pas l'argent
qui les fait bouger c'est pas l'orgueil
les goûts sont des bénévoles ils ont
faire plein de trucs entre le café et
machin vous accueillir ex terrain mais
ils sont là ils sont là parce qu'ils
prennent plaisir
il voit le sens de ce qui est donc
facteur de motivation c'est extrêmement
important
maintenant la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en fait tout
ça quand on est manager qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire de ces deux éléments mais
quelle posture parce qu'on est dans
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
quelle posture je peux prendre moi en
tant que manager en tant que responsable
pour faire en sorte qu'on aille plus
vers le plaisir et le sens dans les
organisations de grandes choses à vous
donner la première c'est pouvoir fixer
un cap ou
fixez une direction dire là on va
toujours cette notion de sens du
pourquoi je vais le développer un peu
plus puis la deuxième chose c'est
remettre un peu d'humain dans les
organisations c'est de l'humain pas que
les process oui non mais alors là non
c'est pas possible parce qu'il ya le le
certificat b 42 et le tu dois remplir
aussi tu as pris ton ticket non parce
que tu as pas pris ton ticket ça va pas
il ya des organisations dans lequel vous
rentrez texto ça m'est arrivé boîte avec
laquelle je bossais vigiles à l'entrée
et cetera donc qui vous demandent votre
pièce d'identité alors vous donnez votre
pièce d'identité puis vous voit une fois
deux fois trois fois quatre fois c'est
une fois dix fois il vous a vu dix fois
il sait qui vous êtes ils vous
accueillent même par votre nom
maintenant c'est lui laurent comment ça
va et c'est qu'un jour j'ai oublié ma
pièce d'identité
qu'est-ce qui se passe ah bah non tu
montes pas tu va rechercher la pièce
d'identité
je vous parle de remettre un peu
d'humain c'est vraiment ça revenons sur
la première partie
la première partie trouver le pourquoi
aujourd'hui nous avons des organisations
lâche pas tout le seul à le dire j'ai
personnes qui s'appelle symons hayek
nous sommes beaucoup dans des
organisations aujourd'hui dans lequel le
on travaille beaucoup sur le comment
comment faire les choses pour vendre
vont entrer dans une boîte il est
possible que parfois on vous disent pas
du tout pouvait aller faire un travail
dont ben voilà tombé au leurre voilà le
manuel de procédure et puis lui c'est
ton chef voilà légende équipe est bonne
journée au revoir moi j'ai vu ça j'ai eu
des services avec lesquels j'ai
travaillé ou les personnes arrivées
période d'intégration c'est bien le but
maintenant et en intégration on vous dit
alors tu t' messi alors ça c'est le code
des marchés publics
et puis on revient la fin de la semaine
voire si tu as survécu et on l'est à
personne tout seul sur son bureau ça
donne envie tout de suite
vous voyez bien en dessous des finalités
le pourquoi précède le comment et le
quoi mais on depuis plusieurs années on
met les choses à l'envers on commence à
travailler sur le comment tu dois faire
les choses on va vous expliquer comment
il faut faire les choses
pensez bien à ça on est dans des
organisations avec une certaine
schizophrénie puisqu'on vous a engagé
pour faire quelque chose on vous engager
pour a priori faire un job
la première chose qu'on vous dit c'est
comment vous devez faire votre job
vous êtes par exemple laborantins et
vous êtes dans un laboratoire d'analysés
médicales et on va vous dire non leur
attention là qu'il faut que tu prennes
l'éprouvette temps et puis que tu mettes
la truck ici l'éguille ici comme ça et
puis après tu vas mettre l'étiquette là
dessus oui j'ai fait huit ans d'études
pour faire ça donc on réapprend mon
boulot c'est en eux sympa puis attention
parce que là il ya là la virgule là non
pas ici plutôt la voilà pourquoi je fais
ça pourquoi en deux mots quelle est la
finalité de mon job c'est certains
d'entre eux sont des entreprises et des
organisations dans lesquelles vous avez
perdu le sens de votre job c'est urgent
de vous remettre autour d'une table pour
vous dire qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
ensemble
mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut définir là où
on a envie d'aller
quelle est la direction commune
condamnant de bâton c'est quelque chose
c'est absolument essentiel
après derrière laisser les gens libres
du comment les organisations aujourd'hui
qui font évoluer leur mode de management
de verre du mode de management tout
versé ce qu'elles font si on définit un
cap et puis après on dit aux personnes
bon vous savez quoi vous a engagé pour
faire un job
allez-y faites le puits si les gens font
des erreurs c'est correct
ils font des erreurs on va apprendre de
nos erreurs
et puis on va progresser là dessus en
première chose pourquoi précède le
comment et quoi garder bien ça en tête
puis deuxième chose comment on remet de
l'humain dans les organisations remettre
de l'humain massa veut dire plusieurs
choses
ça veut dire que mon rôle en tant que
gestionnaire mon rôle en tant que
manager il va évoluer
il va évoluer il va avoir trois choses
complètement différentes plutôt avec le
manager tatillon qu'il dira alors non
excusez-moi mais la tap a bien mis
l'étiquette tu vois on est un petit peu
de travers sur le truc
puis lambert trois heures am et
étiquettes de travers pendant que le
type est en train de crever parce qu'il
a passée résultats des analyses
le commandent devient beaucoup plus
important que pourquoi devriez rire à ce
moment là parce que malheureusement ces
situations car yeux on a tellement
impliqué des procédures parce que
l'étiquette et babya mise qu'un mandat
ni à des gens qui peuvent mourir à cause
de ça nous on revient sur le comment
l'autre truc pour éviter d'être ce
manager tatillon qui va superviser votre
job qui est effectivement pour lui assez
pénible et ont plus la personne qui le
fait si on prend du recul on prend de la
hauteur dessus et puis on reste dans
cette dynamique de dire ma moi mon rôle
c'est d'être un rôle de pilote
le pilote s'est pas forcément celui qui
conduit c'est celui qui donne la
direction
c'est celui qui monte là où google
premiers rôles aujourd'hui qu'on attend
d'un manager c'est un changement de
paradigme c'est un changement d'attitude
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on fasse
confiance aux personnes deuxième type de
rôle a donné aujourd'hui c'est celui
aujourd'hui deux gardiens du temple
quand on travaille sur le pourquoi on
est capable de définir aujourd'hui voilà
on veut aller et là on veut aller
ça s'inscrit par rapport à des attitudes
et comportements qu'on a envie de faire
vivre dans les organisations
faisons les vivres qui assureront du
fait que les gens les mettent en
application pratique si on a des
attitudes et comportements qui sont
d'evian par rapport à ce qu'on a envie
de faire
eh bien il faut avoir le courage d'avoir
des conversations justement courageuse
pour pouvoir faire en sorte que derrière
les gens aillent bien dans le sens de la
longueur
cette notion de gardien du temple est
l'essentiel pilote gardien du temple et
le troisième truc que j'aime beaucoup je
me considère je dis que je suis un
éclaireur mais je suis aussi un
jardinier jardiner c'est quelqu'un qui
fait attention à son sol qui fait
attention à ces différentes plantes on
va pas faire faire pousser des tomates
des carottes de la même façon ni des
papayes ou d euros ce sont les roues il
pousse tous au liban mais on ne va pas
forcément faire les choses de la même
façon donc comment on va porter
attention à chacune des personnes et
plus tôt tu regardes et uniquement ses
faiblesses quelles sont ses forces et
comment en tire ses forces jusqu'à
l'excellence
donc voilà les rôles des managers trois
grands rôles le pilote
le gardien du temple et c'est lui qui a
abandonné va effectivement être le
jardinier qui va permettre de faire
grandir toute son équipe le rôle d'un
leader aujourd'hui c'est pas uniquement
de contrôler le rôle d'un leader c'est
de générer d'autres leaders ça demande
trois grandes choses et je vais conclure
avec ça on va conclure et 3c première
chose ça demande d'avoir déjà confiance
confiance en les autres ce qui n'est pas
facile mais confiance en soi confiance
en soi ça veut dire aussi se connaître
soi même ça c'est vraiment absolument
indispensable ça c'est le premier c'est
le deuxième c'est derrière ça va
demander une vertu absolument essentiel
aujourd'hui qu'est cette capacité
derrière avoir conscience des actes
qu'on fait aujourd'hui la conscience des
actes que l'on pose la conscience des
gestes la conscience des attitudes la
conscience du non verbal
c'est absolument indispensable parfois
vous pouvez détruire une personne juste
par une attitude juste par amour
juste par un geste donc avoir cette
confiance est absolument indispensable
puis la troisième chose et je conclurai
en avec ça ça ne demande du courage du
courage pour se remettre en question du
courage pour accepter ses erreurs du
courage pour tomber du courage pour se
relever du courage pour réussir
alors je vous souhaite et je ne souhaite
beaucoup de courage et un excellent tmx
merci m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]